bien en este vídeo vamos a conectar
nuestras luces led las luces led van a
ser usadas para probar varias partes del
circuito y además serán nuestros ojos
los leds están polarizados lo que
significa que es importante la dirección
en la que fluye la energía a través de
estos leds los leds comúnmente tienen
una pata corta y una pata larga la pata
larga es generalmente positiva así que
queremos estar seguros que unimos
nuestras dos patas largas juntas ya que
si conectamos una parte corta y una pata
larga entonces tendremos problemas y no
funcionará de la manera en la que
queremos así que vamos a buscar las dos
patas largas y una vez que tengamos
determinadas las dos patas largas vamos
a doblarlas hacia afuera para así poder
conectarlas ya sabemos que aquí hay dos
patas positivas juntas así que vamos a
trenzar las muy bien una con la otra y
queremos asegurarnos de que el trenzado
muy apretado de modo que tengamos una
muy buena conexión sólida solo siguen
tensando las patas de estos leds hasta
que estén completamente trenzadas una
con la otra
probablemente nos llevará de cinco a
diez vueltas trenzar las por completo
observa que tenemos las patas negativas
de los leds hacia afuera y las patas
positivas
ahora están trenzadas en el interior y
ahora lo que necesitamos es conectar los
leds a los interruptores y bueno para
conectar dos leds a los interruptores
primero vamos a tomar un poco del cable
rojo que tenemos en nuestro equipo y
vamos a pelar cerca de media pulgada de
ese cable rojo y vamos a introducir ese
cable rojo a través de los conectores
superiores con cuidado hay agujeros muy
pequeños en cada uno de los conectores
en la parte posterior de nuestros
interruptores así que estoy tratando de
pasar este cable a través de ellos
agujeros y probablemente esta sea la
parte más difícil del cableado de todo
el robot ya que requiere de dobles el
cable en un tipo de bucle alargado o en
forma de gancho para poder meterlo a
través de estos agujeros para cada
conector y para eso tomaremos nuestras
confiables piensas de punta y si toma un
poco de tiempo hacerlo pero se puede
lograr se debe de poder pasar el cable a
través de ambos agujeros y esto ayudará
a asegurarnos que la conexión sea buena
y ya está lo logremos ya tenemos el
cable adentro de ambos agujeros y luego
simplemente doblaremos el cable hacia
arriba a un ángulo de 90 grados con
respecto al conector que está al
interior y voy a hacer un acercamiento
solo para estar seguro de que puedes ver
lo que está sucediendo a fin de que este
robot en particular esté construido para
funcionar debemos asegurarnos de que
estos cables están pensados o doblados
con fuerza contra los dos contactos
ya que si hay mucho espacio entre el
cable y el contacto el robot podría no
funcionar de la manera que queremos así
que estamos tomando nuestras pinzas de
punta introduciendo las en estos
espacios apretados entre el cable y los
contactos y doblando esos cables
firmemente contra las conexiones y vamos
a usar nuestros leds para asegurarnos de
que esta conexión es buena y la energía
está fluyendo así que lo siguiente que
necesitamos hacer es recortar un poco en
nuestro cable entonces vamos a cortar
cerca de 2 pulgadas del cable y bueno
podemos fijarnos mejor en lo que nos
sobra del cable
el cable restante debe de ser
aproximadamente de una pulgada y media y
ya que tenemos este cable ahora vamos a
quitar cerca de media pulgada de
aislante con nuestro pelador de cable y
recuerda este es un cable calibre 22 así
que realmente angosto y por eso vamos a
usar el pelador para cable más pequeño
que tenemos en nuestras pinzas
este es un pelador de cable de muy bajo
costo así que debes de girar un poco
para lograr que el aislante salga bien
ahora tenemos allí nuestro cable rojo y
también tenemos un cable rojo que viene
desde nuestra batería y lo que vamos a
hacer ahora es conectar nuestro cable
rojo de la batería al cable rojo que
acabamos de conectar a los interruptores
de un polo y dos posiciones y también
vamos a quitar un poco más de aislante
de este cable ya que recuerdan que lo
hicimos un poco más largo así que si
este cable mide aproximadamente 2
pulgadas vamos a quitar cerca de tres
cuartos de pulgada de aislante con
nuestro pelador de cable también deben
de ser cuidadosos con este cable de
hilos ya que no es sólido así que es
fácil de romper los hilos mientras lo
estás pelando tómate tu tiempo para
quitar el aislante para que aún estén
conectados todos estos hilos
eléctricamente conductivos entonces
vamos a tomar esos hilos y lo que
podemos hacer es tomar este cable y lo
vamos a envolver al revés
del cable de núcleo sólido es decir del
cable que acabamos de conectar a los
interruptores y las mejores conexiones
están envueltas de manera firme así que
queremos estar seguros de que todos los
hilos están fuertemente conectados
alrededor del cable del núcleo sólido de
cobre y con eso vamos a poder conectar
el lado positivo de nuestra batería a
nuestros leds y también a otros
componentes de una manera sencilla
ahora vamos a tomar nuestros leds y
vamos a conectar las resistencias a los
leds las resistencias evitan que los
leds tomen demasiada corriente y se
quemen así que de nuevo vamos a poner la
pata de la resistencia a un ángulo de
aproximadamente 90 grados y la vamos a
conectar a la pata opuesta del led y lo
que vamos a hacer es enrollar las una
con la otra al menos unas 4 o 5 veces si
no es que más las necesarias para
asegurar que tenemos una conexión
realmente sólida con esta pata de leds
de nuevo esta es la pata negativa y las
resistencias pueden ir
para tan negativa o positiva pero en
este vídeo escogimos las patas negativas
que son las que están hacia afuera de
nuevo vamos a hacer lo mismo con esta
otra pata de esta otra resistencia y con
la otra pata de los leds y lo vamos a
hacer hasta que esté bien y firmemente
conectada es importante que estas
vueltas que hicimos con la pata de la
resistencia estén bien apretadas y
firmemente unidas a la pata del led bien
ahora tenemos nuestros leds armados y
podemos empezar a conectarlos a los
cables rojos que acabamos de enrollar
pero antes de enrollar los vamos a ver
si todo funciona como debería y lo que
voy a hacer es mover un poco a esto para
que puedan ver y ahora sí ahí vamos
observa que si tenemos energía a través
de los cables esto de un lado y ahora
vamos a probar el otro lado y esto nos
asegura que que hablamos los leds
correctamente así que bien observa ya
está lo hicimos bien y este es un
circuito de bastante bajo voltaje un
circuito de corriente bastante baja ya
que podemos
de hecho usar nuestras manos para
conectar estas cosas ahora vamos a
conectar nuestros leds ya que ahora
estamos seguros de que la energía puede
fluir correctamente a través de ellos y
ahora vamos a enrollar los cables
nuestros cables rojos alrededor de las
patas positivas de los leds que
recuerdan son las patas que teníamos
enrolladas en medio
ahora vamos a trenzar todo junto y tal
vez esto sea un poco difícil si lo es
siempre puedes tomar tus pinzas de punta
y pensarlo un poco mejor asegúrate de
que los cables estén conectados
firmemente recuerda entre mejor sea esta
conexión será más confiable así que es
bien importante asegurarse de que esta
conexión sea
bien una vez que tenemos esos cables
unidos y los leds entonces podemos tomar
un pedazo de papel aluminio y éste lo
vamos a envolver alrededor sólo para
ayudar a garantizar que los cables están
sólidamente conectados y que conducen la
energía no forzosamente deben de usar
papel aluminio es solo una precaución
adicional pero básicamente nos permite
asegurarnos de que si hay un cable o
conexión a sueltos entonces tengan
conductividad eléctrica al ponerles es
de aluminio pero de nuevo no
necesariamente debes de poner este papel
aluminio bien ahora vamos a tomar un
poco de material aislante que será esta
cinta de aislar y vamos a envolverla
alrededor del papel aluminio y por lo
tanto alrededor de dos cables trenzados
y eso debería ayudar a mantener todo en
su lugar y que tengamos una conexión
confiable y bueno espera está un poco
fuera de la imagen así que voy a moverlo
de vuelta a la imagen y ahora vamos a
envolver esta cinta de ésta
lo más fuerte posible alrededor de esta
conexión para ayudar a mantener todo
perfectamente en su lugar ahora lo que
vamos a hacer es conectar la pata de
nuestra resistencia que teníamos suelta
y nuestro cambio negativo en negro de
nuestras baterías a las dos terminales
libres en nuestros interruptores el
interruptor encenderá o apagar a al led
dependiendo la terminal en que se
conecten así que deben de tener cuidado
de no dejarlo por mucho tiempo encendido
ya que cuando se apaguen puede causar un
cortocircuito y eso provocará que los
cables se calienten por eso es
importante probar los leds y asegurarnos
de que todas las conexiones son las
adecuadas y como lo son entonces
pondremos silicón caliente en los cables
rojos que recuerdan son los cables
terminales positivos y eso evitará que
se muevan y además nos ayudará a
mantenerlos unidos contra los
interruptores de un polo y dos
posiciones